what's your name man corey corey all
right hold on a second you're gonna stay
right here corey
good to meet you nice to meet you okay
are you nervous no
all right good yeah
you're pretty stupid if you're not
nervous
[Music]
okay here's what we're gonna do i want
you to
[ __ ] see [ __ ] i want you to hold this
like this
now you have to see it because you have
to see the lyrics
[Laughter]
that's what i'm talking about this works
way better for me thank you so much
i thought it would be funny to write a
song where all of the lyrics were just
actual headlines written about florida
man
so i wrote this today and let's see i'm
gonna do a little chorus first and see
if it sounds good i haven't decided on
what tune this is gonna be in yet okay
all right that's fine
[Laughter]
all my songs are g c and d so i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
all right it's called florida man i'm
gonna do chorus first and then we'll go
through there i'll tell you what
i'm not gonna do that one i'll
definitely do that one and i'll
definitely do that one
i'll do that one
florida man always doing the best that
he can
florida man suspected of using a private
plane
to draw a giant radar penis
[Music]
florida man breaks into jail
to hang out
[Music]
with his friends
florida man denies drinking and driving
says he only drank bourbon
at the stop signs
[Music]
florida man stabs tourists
despite having no
arms
florida man doing the best that he can
[Music]
florida man pauses police chase to
rehydrate with stolen capri sun
[Applause]
says smoking crack makes him thirsty
florida man disguises himself in
a bull costume as he tries to burn
down his former lover's house with pasta
sauce
florida man arrested in local park
for practice in karate
on the swans
[Music]
i'm gonna end right there and florida
man
proudly claims he's the first ever man
to vape semen
thank you so much
[Applause]
corey everybody let him hear it one time
[Music]
a co-op for air different
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]